-I have a big announcement
I have to make tonight.
-What's that?
-This is a giant, giant deal.
I'm very excited about this.
So I've been working
on a holiday song, okay?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
A comedy song and...
you work on it
and The Roots know
is not easy to really --
It's takes time
to write and produce
and mix and do all stuff.
So I've been working on this.
I'm working on different songs.
They're funny,
but then, I got one song --
Because I'm in Electric Lady
Studios here in Manhattan.
After the show, I go there
from like 7:00 to midnight
and just hang out and just try
to write and things.
So, you see people
in the building,
who's there and stuff,
so they go,
"Why don't you meet
with this producer?"
A guy named Ido, and Aldi
are these two producers
and they know how
to write music.
So I get to these guys
and we write this song
and I think it's something.
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
-I think
we could have something.
-Whoa!
-I've never written a song
where I go like,
"We got something."
-Well.
-I go, "That's funny,"
or whatever.
But this one, I go,
"This is something."
[ Laughter ]
So I go to the record label.
I went
to Michele Anthony's house
and Monte Lipman was there
and I played the song for them.
This is the heads of the label.
I played the song.
It's a demo.
I play it.
Listen to it, loud.
The kids are there.
Song ends. Quiet.
[ Laughter ]
No one says anything.
-Oh.
-Monte stands up.
He come over to me.
He goes,
"You got a hit."
-Yeah!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-So you know Monte, right?
-Yeah.
-So I go, "Now, what do we do?"
Because it's, you know --
so, anyways, I'm like,
it's basically about like
how last year was just rough
on everybody
and, you know,
I wanted to say like, you know,
it's going to get better.
It really is going
to get better.
Trust me.
And how can I portray that
and also think
about what funny things happened
while we were in lockdown,
you know.
Putting Purell on everything
[ Laughter ]
or, you know,
going onto Zoom,
Zooming your grandpa,
[ Laughter ]
you know, grandma
and seeing where
the Wi-Fi works best.
So we start writing the song.
They go, "Well, our dream is
Ariana Grande
to do the song with."
I go, "Wow.
Good luck."
[ Laughter ]
I mean, but whatever.
She's the greatest.
I mean, she's gorgeous.
She can sing like an angel.
She's funny.
We've had her --
We've been friends
since "Late Night,"
you know, Ariana Grande.
So I go, "Well, why not?
Let's just go out to her
and see if she wants to do it."
We go out to her.
We don't hear back.
Okay, good. But whatever.
[ Laughter ]
I know she's fine.
I see her on "The Voice."
She's fine.
[ Laughter ]
I got a text from Ariana.
"Jimmy, I love the song.
I'm in."
-Oh.
-I mean, the song --
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Whoa!
-So, now, I know this is --
-I want to hear this.
-I know, I know. I got
to tell you the story, though.
So it's great.
So like maybe two months ago,
the song was nothing.
It just wasn't going anywhere.
I didn't know --
We didn't hear back
for anything.
I go, "I guess it just
won't come out."
It's just the way life works.
Okay.
Ariana says, "I'm in.
I'm out in L.A.,
doing 'That's My Jam.'"
She goes, "I'm in. I'm recording
tomorrow at the studio."
Records her track,
does backing vocals.
My song sounds better
than it was.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoa.
-Whoo!
-It's unbelievable.
I go, "This is unbelievable."
She goes, "Who's going
to do the rap on the song?"
Because, on the demo, I rapped.
[ Laughter ]
I was hoping --
-Hey, hey, hey, don't laugh!
-I was hoping she'd say,
No, Jimmy, you can do the rap."
[ Laughter ]
She goes, "Maybe we should see
if Meg wants to do the rap."
[ Audience ohs ]
I'm like, "Megan Thee Stallion?"
She's like, "Yeah."
I got to hang up the phone.
[ Laughter ]
Hold on. It's like freaking out.
So I'm getting sweats
and I'm freaking out.
I go, "Now,
this is a real song."
Text Megan Thee Stallion.
Megan Thee Stallion goes,
I get to do a song
with my besties
Ariana and Jimmy?
I'm in.
When do we shoot the video?"
[ Cheering and applause ]
Dude, Quest, I didn't tell you
about it, though.
Dude, this all happened
in like a month.
-Okay.
-I didn't tell you this
because I didn't want to --
I mean, you got your own stuff.
Your, you know.
-Ah, you know.
-Yeah, "Summer of Soul."
-Can't do everything.
-We're lucky to get
to do these things.
So, anyways, we recorded
a song and a video.
It's called
"It Was A...(Masked Christmas)."
Ariana Grande,
Megan Thee Stallion.
[ Cheering and applause ]
It drops tonight.
It drops tonight at midnight.
[ Cheering intensifies ]
-Whoa!
-So it's out tonight!
I'm freaking out!
Like this is major.
Like I'm seriously, really
seriously reacting to this
like this
because this is major --
I'm on an actual record label
with real stars.
[ Laughter ]
Like the biggest of the big.
Stunner, Megan Thee Stallion.
I mean, and I get to debut it.
It's out at midnight, so,
whatever you stream music on,
put it on repeat,
whatever you can do to help me.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Put it on a playlist.
Send it to Grandpa.
I would love it.
Thank you, all the radio
stations, for playing it.
But it's out at midnight.
But, right now,
they're allowing us to debut it,
[ Cheering and applause ]
a world premiere,
on our show tonight.
-Whoa!
-So please enjoy my new song,
"It Was A...(Masked Christmas),"
by me, Ariana Grande,
and Megan Thee Stallion.
Here we go.
♪ [ Bells jingling ] ♪
-What's up, y'all?
[ Echoing ]
It's Megan Thee Stallion,
Ariana Grande,
and Jimmy Fallon.
Y'all know what time it is.
It's time on get those boosters.
[ Laughter ]
Agh!
-♪ It was a...masked Christmas ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪ We stayed in the house ♪
♪ We covered our nose ♪
♪ And covered our mouth ♪
♪ But it's Christmastime ♪
♪ We'll be in line
for a booster ♪
♪ Ah ah ♪
-♪ For a booster ♪
-♪ It was a...masked Christmas ♪
♪ We up in a Zoom ♪
♪ I can only get Wi-Fi ♪
♪ In the laundry room ♪
♪ But it's Christmastime ♪
♪ We'll be in line
for a booster ♪
♪ Oh oh ♪
-♪ I need somebody
to hold tonight ♪
♪ 'Cause it's gonna snow ♪
♪ It's gonna snow ♪
♪ I need somebody
to hold me tight ♪
♪ And never let go ♪
-♪ Never let go ♪
[ Laughter ]
-♪ So say that
you're coming home ♪
♪ You know it's
Christmas Eve ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Last year,
I were here alone ♪
♪ Don't tell me
this year's the same ♪
-♪ It's not the same ♪
-♪ The same ♪
-♪ It was a...masked Christmas ♪
♪ We stayed in the house ♪
♪ We covered our nose ♪
♪ And covered our mouth ♪
♪ But it's Christmastime ♪
♪ We'll be in line
for a booster ♪
♪ Ah ah ♪
-♪ For a booster ♪
-♪ It was a...masked Christmas ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ We up in a Zoom ♪
♪ I can only get Wi-Fi ♪
♪ In the laundry room ♪
♪ But it's Christmastime ♪
♪ We'll be in line
for a booster ♪
-♪ Aye aye aye ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪ This Christmas,
I'mma make it count ♪
♪ No more quarantine
on the couch, yeah ♪
♪ This year,
hang that mistletoe ♪
♪ I'mma kiss everybody
that I know ♪
Mwah!
♪ This year's different,
you can tell ♪
♪ Deck those halls
and jingle bells ♪
♪ Put Purell on everything ♪
♪ Turkey, eggnog, candy cane ♪
♪ Hey, ho ♪
♪ There's a good chance
of snow, yeah ♪
♪ Hey, ho ♪
♪ Somebody wipe Rudolph's nose ♪
[ Sneezes ]
♪ Ho, hey ♪
♪ I promise we'll be okay ♪
-♪ 'Cause, now, we're in line ♪
♪ For a booster ♪
-♪ Aye, aye, aye ♪
Agh!
-♪ It was a...masked Christmas ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ We stayed in the house ♪
♪ We covered our nose ♪
♪ And covered our mouth ♪
♪ But it's Christmastime ♪
♪ We'll be in line
for a booster ♪
♪ Ah ah ♪
-♪ For a booster ♪
-♪ It was a...masked Christmas ♪
♪ We up in a Zoom ♪
♪ I can only get Wi-Fi ♪
♪ In the laundry room ♪
♪ But it's Christmastime ♪
♪ We'll be in line
for a booster ♪
♪ Ah ah ♪
-♪ For a booster ♪
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Oh!
-Come on!
Yes!
-[ Laughs ]
-Thanks to our great director,
Dan Opsal.
Thank you to Ariana Grande.
Thank you
to Megan Thee Stallion.
"It Was A...(Masked Christmas)"
available at midnight.
Spread the word, everybody!
Oh, my gosh!